what governs free will is mathematics or
you think it's something completely
different
and this goes back to our reductionist
account okay yeah mathematics we we
should talk about mathematics and uh
and determinism
um but
no i think
mathematics again and especially today's
mathematics has very very little to say
on
probably nothing to say on free will and
and consciousness
the reason i say that is that when one
says well it's first in the logical
order the way i'm thinking is of the
traditional reductionist view and you go
down and down until you get to physics
and then sometimes people encapsulate
physics into math and then if free will
is first well then free will is prior to
math is that the correct way of looking
at it as these nested sets or is that
different i shouldn't be thinking about
it like that
i don't think you should be thinking of
nested
stats mathematics is
i guess it's really a kind of different
branch of
of science and of understanding
and again mathematics
you in french we say
the mathematics it's really a plural
and indeed there are different
sources of mathematics you can really
think of mathematics as kind of
you know these purely platonistic view
where there are these mathematical
objects existing
you know outside of time outside of the
physical world
um
they just have their own existence with
their own
rules um
now again okay i'm probably not
prepared to really you know argue how
these rules uh
uh
you know they depend on the axioms
in principle but okay
quite a lot of basic things like you
know the integers for instance the
integer five
does it exist by itself in this
platonistic world i guess that's the
view that most mathematicians would
approach will admit
but there are there are different sorts
of mathematics you have also mathematics
where people were more thinking
in terms of
that the mathematical objects would
themselves be
processes that develop and evolve in
time
okay the best example here is
intuitionistic mathematics that was
mostly
developed by uh brower
uh a hundred years ago about about a
hundred years ago
uh still today some people developing
this form of mathematics that come under
the general umbrella of constructivists
but in this specific form of
constructivism called intuitionism
you really have that already at the
mathematical level
even numbers like okay what we call real
numbers are really evolving in time
and then if mathematics includes that
kind of and in unneeds the concept or
introduces the concept of time already
even at the level of numbers
then that makes this sort of mathematics
much closer
and possibly better suited
for for physics for science in general
so when you see mathematics it's not
clear what you mean
many of the people watching don't know
what constructivism what is it
constructionist
because it's not constructivism isn't it
constructivist well
i know there's social constructivism and
social construction i don't want to mix
that up
well i know intuitionism and i've always
seen intuitionism as the same as
the constructionist view in mathematics
but you just said that intuitionist is a
specific subset of constructionist what
would be an example of a constructionist
that is not an intuitionist
so constructivist just means that every
object one should be able to construct
them now it depends do you want to be
able to construct them now
and period is done
or
is it enough to have a rule that tells
you how the process of constructing
these these objects
develops in time
so somehow they are never finished
there are at least some of these
processes that will never finish
so they evolve in time and that's then
intuitionism
so intuitionism the intuition is that
things can evolve in time admittedly
brower when he developed that he was
thinking
about you know you you may define a
number
uh
depending on some mathematical
conjecture
and depending how this conjecture will
turn out you know true or false the
number maybe
zero one let's say and so the number is
undefined until
this conjecture this specific conjecture
is solved but that brings now
mathematics or this form of
intuitionistic mathematics very much to
what humans are able to do
prove or not prove this uh
conjecture
while my understanding and other
people's understanding of intuition is
just that as time passes new information
gets created continuously
and hence
a number may evolve according to this
new information